euromax highlights and here's your host
ann o'donnell hello and welcome to
euromax highlights well we've compiled
our favorite reports of the week for you
let's have a look at what's coming up
toy perspective photographing live from
the point of view of a lego figurine
coffee clash the best baristi compete at
the world championship
on racy tour we visit monaco's top
attractions along its grand prix track
but the oscars of the youtube generation
is an award ceremony in germany for the
best online videos up to 7 000 videos
compete for the top titles in 13
different categories we caught up with
the german filmmaker who won in the
action category
revenge of the beast is not your average
skateboarder film
its spectacular cinematography turns the
street sport into an art form
the film's director sebastian linda is
an avid skater himself
for him it was a labor of love from
start to finish
revenge of the beasts was meant to take
viewers under the board
you can share the excitement with them
when you're flying through the air
so you have to develop a visual language
for others to see
the advantage of being a skateboarder
and a filmmaker is having the camera
path wherever you have tarmac
the camera is totally steady with no
wobbles
i used to shoot skateboard videos that
way
but now it's become my trademark
now when i'm making music videos i have
the board mounted camera for 80 of my
shots
sebastian linda is a versatile filmmaker
his resume includes music videos for the
german new age ambient outfit schiller
to recordings of his many travels across
the globe
to do something new and unconventional
to get that inspiration you have to go
out and see something else
it's about finding your feet again
and traveling is essential for that
when shooting a documentary about a
faith healer in bali he used a different
camera to the one he'd normally have for
promotional films
his equipment and methodology vary
according to the subject
the only thing that remains constant is
his style of filming
every millimeter of movement makes a
huge difference
it's always about finding the right
place in the right shot
you also have to risk all the equipment
everything
you have to work out how it's going to
look with a skater coming towards me or
jumping over me
then pan towards the light
sometimes sebastian linda edits his
material right where he shot it so he
can upload a trailer version to the
internet there and then
i like sharing my films with the world
in the old days
you were limited to a particular tv
station or festival
and now there's this massive global
audience when you upload a film plus you
get feedback online
ivana
sebastian linda also uses the internet
to finance his films via crowdfunding
websites
he posts clips to keep his benefactors
up to date on how his projects are
progressing
for me it's also a tool for attracting
people to a project in advance and
encouraging them to get involved
so it's marketing as well as funding
funding
he's currently editing the follow-up to
his acclaimed revenge of the beasts
this time with 10 skaters out on the
streets of indonesia
the film also reveals how the locals
young and old alike reacted to a sport
largely unknown in their country
the great thing about my kind of films
is that you can just live your life with
the camera running
the good moments happen by themselves
it's not like going to work
if i look back on our trip
i'm not thinking about the camera
i have all those moments in my head and
i forget the camera
there are moments i've experienced
myself
you might not want to try these stunts
at home
but you can experience the onboard
thrills and spills from the safety of
your own screen
well in most german cities it's almost a
given that you will find a currywurst
stand it is germany's traditional
version of fast food but it's not just
popular with germans tourists like it so
much that startup companies realize
there was a demand for it outside of
germany nowadays you can find
traditional german sausages served in
many corners of europe and it's a trend
that looks definitely set to stay
this snack bar looks just like any other
in berlin or cologne but it's in central
warsaw
wurst kiosk as it's known specializes in
german sausages and it's a hit
it has a fine flavor
and it's very delicately spiced
perfectly grilled too
it tastes really good
i've never been to germany but these
seem like the real thing
it tastes great after work
i have one almost every day i really
like them
wherever german expats live you'll find
german sausage normally but the man
behind this sausage bar is polish
bernard roselle used to be an
advertising he developed a taste for the
meaty german treat on business trips he
opened his first stand just in time for
the euro 2012 soccer championship in
poland
i found a niche because no one was
selling
german sausages
here in warsaw
and actually polish people like sausages
grilled sausages especially during the
the summer so i thought to myself that
is a good starting point to open a small
small hole in the wall
roussel imports his product from just
across the border his snack bar or imbus
in german offers six varieties of
sausage meals and the top seller
currywurst a true berlin delicacy
had several meetings with various indies
in germany in germany and
i
just
watched how they are being prepared and
how they are served
with hot curry sauce and some you know
little things that are important for
german people and that's the way it goes
just like you know in berlin
about a million and a half tons of
sausage are produced in germany annually
about a fifth of that total gets
exported
to london for instance
the british capital boasts several
sausage stands one of the best known is
hermenza german
since opening three years ago it's made
a name for itself as the worst place to
go
the owners are german's florian frye and
aseda falakashi
they get their sausage straight from the
black forest from their neighborhood
butcher
they started out with just a catering
mobile
and then expanded to two restaurants
we never expected
we started out really small and went our
way and of course we're super happy that
things turned out the way they did
and in another corner of europe there
they are again at portugal's
southwestern tip you'll find the last
bratwurst stand before america
from spring till fall petra and wolfgang
bald sell their nurnberg style sausage
imported by air cargo
most of our customers are from spain but
of course we get lots of germans too
they've been satisfying customers for 17
years now
divorced kiosk in warsaw is branching
out now with some newsstands
and there are even mobile worst wagons
crisscrossing poland so what's the
secret
it's simple that it stays good
that's the way it is
any way you slice them smoke them fry
them or steam them come and get your
german sausages before someone else does
well lego man has seen many of britain's
sights and captured them all on his
camera in tandem photographer andrew
white has captured him capturing them
and this series of photos is proving a
big hit online playing with people's
perception of size and space is a
popular development in the world of
photography and andrew white does it all
with the mobile phone
the world viewed through the eyes of a
little lego person
the locations may be familiar but
captured from a pint-sized perspective
they look quite different
it's all part of a project by
photographer andrew white
the idea for the minifigure photography
came because we were on a family trip to
the lego store and my children found a
minifigure which had a camera accessory
and as a photographer myself i
immediately saw the potential of being
able to take this figure with me and
sort of tell a story from his point of
view looking at looking at him over the
shoulder as he goes around taking photos
white set out exploring the
possibilities and quickly decided to
abandon his regular camera in favor of a
smartphone
it has one major advantage
turned upside down the lens is almost at
ground level
literally within the first week of
having the figure i tried a couple of
shots of with my proper equipment um and
i found that i couldn't get close enough
to the figure and still have it in focus
and also the
the depth of field that i was achieving
meant that the the background was too
out of focus it just wasn't recognizable
many of the shots have been posted on
facebook but white also sells prints on
his website
when i'm looking for an opportunity to
take a photo then i'm looking usually
for either a well-known landmark like
we're in front of some paul's cathedral
today
or i'm looking for a scene that people
can relate to and i can portray in
perhaps a slightly different way
you know i've been able to capture
various different weather situations
they all make a a dramatic photo in
their own way
my favorite is
where the figure is sort of standing
looking at a rainbow but not actually
taking a photo he's just got his camera
down by his side um and it's kind of
reminding reminding us that you know
occasionally there's views that you need
to actually put the camera down and just
look and take it all in
andrew white isn't the only photographer
to work in miniature for the past few
years london-based artist sling katyu
has been creating small street scenes
populated by tiny people
he's published several volumes of
photographs and shown them in
exhibitions
two paris-based photographers who go by
the name of mini-miyam have also gotten
in on the act
their little people live on edible
landscapes and have exciting adventures
in germany tomas vreda sets toy models
in actual landscapes and takes close-ups
of them as though they were real
i'm certainly not the first person to
use small toys or lego in my photography
there's a lot of it
there's a lot of it happening there's a
lot of it predates what i'm doing um i
think what's what's different about what
i'm doing is doing it from the
perspective of a photographer so you're
actually understanding the story it's
very good to
to kind of contribute to a narrative and
to keep to keep things going from day to
day
he's dubbed his work legography
and also plans to put out a photo volume
soon
not too long ago andrew white decided to
give his lego person some company a crew
of tiny superheroes setting out to
conquer the world
be warned
want to learn more about europe and
european culture visit euromax on
facebook
you can tell us what you think and
you'll never miss an interesting topic
many euromax reports can also be looked
at again
there are behind the scenes looks at how
the reports and the program are
produced
we like it when fans visit euromax on
facebook
well a standard filter coffee can vary
widely in taste depending on where the
coffee bean comes from how they're
roasted and ground drinking coffee has
become about so much more than just a
caffeine fix here in europe and the
demand for a good brew is rising since
the year 2000 there has even been a
world cup for the best barista and this
year it was held in rimini italy having
already qualified in their own countries
54 internationals competed over four
days for the capital title
making coffee is a science in and of
itself
at the world barrista championship in
the italian resort of rimini everyone's
a pro they know their beans the right
roast
and how to get the grounds just fine
milk and water are also of the essence
everyone who brews up coffee has their
own recipe for the perfect cup
every second in your mouth the the mouth
feel and the flavor they change and give
you like a really movement and this is
what i'm looking in a blend how fine do
you want to grind your coffee or who how
course
so the grinder is like the main thing
it's a chain and every link has to fit
together from the producer right down to
the barista
during the four day competition each one
of the 54 coffee crazy contestants has
to serve the international jury
cappuccino espresso and a unique
beverage of their own called a signature
drink
the jury is specialized in analyzing the
complex aromas of the java served here
they've got certificates and years of
experience
many are world barista championship
veterans themselves
what you could see in the last couple of
years that baristas that are actually
competing and you know what ambassadors
for specialty coffee they interact much
more with the origin you know they know
much more and so as a judge you also
have to keep up you know just train
yourself and read a lot and travel a lot
just to keep up with the
knowledge all the competitors here are
gaining
anna toastbag is the german hopeful she
studied archaeology and first rose to
the coffee challenge helping out at a
cafe in munster
it inspired her to train to be a barista
for two and a half years she's been
leading the coffee school at the host
bar where she started out now she trains
new talent
her skills won her the german
championship last year
you can compare them and taste them and
notice wow that one's nutty the other
chocolatey and another is fruity that's
amazing there's always something new and
that just blew me away
her latest discovery is a pure
non-blended coffee from ethiopia the
homeland of the arabica bean
there she found beans she roasted in
various ways until she found just the
taste she wanted she's in the right
place at the right time germans are
suddenly raising the bar when it comes
to coffee
many people want to be able to taste
more aromas and they want to know
exactly where their coffee is from the
specific region
so interest in coffee has grown and
that's great
but there's still plenty of room for
improvement
scandinavians are the role models to
surpass in rimini
since the first championship in monaco
in 2000 scandinavians have won the title
six times
not surprising for the world's top
coffee consumers
dain sur and stila moccasin is at his
ninth championship
he says coffee is like a wine whose
flavors must be teased out and he says
the quality just keeps getting better
and better
i think it would be very interesting to
see
how
bars are set up with machines
because that's also changing this whole
line of you know industry where
express machines as you saw in old days
in italy with all the living machines i
mean that's coming back
so things just keep improving coffee has
now been claimed by the connoisseurs
and the experts at the competition in
italy are making sure their exacting
standards are met
and it was hidden izaki of japan who won
this year's world barista championship
so i'm sure all those customers are
fairly happy about that now once every
year in may the streets of monaco are
closed for the grand prix it's situated
on the french riviera and euromax went
along for the annual bash we did stray
from the track occasionally though just
to show you some of the other
attractions in the area
the race that goes through the center of
monaco starts on the busy albert the
first boulevard
german race car driver ellen law has
been living here for more than 20 years
and uses the boulevard daily
now and then i think here i am sitting
in the quiet neighborhood of la connamin
with a coffee
and a few years ago actually a bit
longer than that
50 meters from here i was holding the
trophy in my hands 50 meters
the peaceful quarter of la condamine is
located right alongside albert the first
boulevard
next to the palace cliffs known as the
rock la condemine is the oldest part of
monaco
it's now been made into a pedestrian
zone
is located right next to the starting
line
it's dominated by old buildings and
apartments that don't have elevators
lokonomin is the opposite of hustle and
bustle
for me it's the most pleasant area here
there are plenty of nice shops far away
from the malls
you can shop and stroll too
many
we move on to the small church that
marks the spot where the start and
finish straightaways end
sant devote is where the course begins
winding its way up to the casino
monaco's most famous landmark
the place du casino glitters with a
glamour associated with the principality
international jet setting guests party
year round at the hotel de paris
monaco native ari doria has been
watching the goings on here for 70 years
it might not be a symbol of monaco but
it's a pretty typical site here the
plastic casino is where ferraris meet
and greet
this is where luxury gathers it's been
that way for a decade
the casino was the start of monaco's
wealth
from the place to casino the race course
heads back downhill towards the fairmont
a luxury hotel built in the middle of a
cliff above the sea
the best view of the tightest curve in
the grand prix can be had from the roof
terrace pool
it's something that former silver arrow
driver sterling moss enjoys he and his
wife susie are regulars here of course
they stay in the suite named after him
images of his monaco victories decorate
the walls the suite has a balcony
overlooking the water
it's in the right place
you've got a fantastic view and they go
past
and you know i think it's magic i mean
even even without bothering about the
grand prix it's sort of lovely you know
beautiful
dining room and everything oh i love it
yeah i'm not sure how i feel about you
looking down from the bedroom well i
figured
i'm picking up hints
i followed fans here and this thing i'm
moting him
after the hairpin turns around the
fairmont hotel there's a straight
stretch through the tunnel
but of course that doesn't mean you can
drive fast here
it's too bad but you have to obey the
traffic laws
legendary paris dakar rally winner yota
kleinschmidt is always happy to get back
into the light at the end of the tunnel
that's when there's a view of monaco's
yacht harbor por er cool
the ships that tie up here seem to get
bigger with each passing year
there are plenty of restaurants down at
port side particularly in the west
opposite the raskas curve which brings
the grand prix drivers back to the main
straight away
you miss a lot driving through here at
speed just like michael schumacher did
with his best time of 1 minute and 14
seconds
during the day you can have a coffee and
see more boats than you're likely to see
in many other places
and come evening it turns into a nice
promenade
in the bars and restaurants that line
the course the odds are pretty good at
any time of the year that you'll meet a
star race car driver because not
surprisingly many of them live in monaco
well thanks for watching that is it from
me and o'donnell and the rest of the
euromax crew for today if you miss
anything you can always catch up with us
online see you tomorrow bye
you